maxence norick bonjour bonjour merci de
nous accueillir à cette table dans
l'enceinte de la boutique guerlain de la
cour des senteurs qui fête ses un an
mais bon vous êtes son directeur et je
crois que vous animez aussi des ateliers
dont on a entendu parler et plus
précisément l'atelier création afin
qu'on appelle les contes parfumés les
contes parfumés
voilà alors moi c'est celui ci qui me
fait plus rêver et je suis inscrite là
ça y est c'est fait alors on va
justement alors je peux pas vous faire
tout un atelier parce que ça prendrait
trop de temps puisqu'il dure deux heures
et demie mais j'ai quand même vous
expliquer quelques notions de parfume de
parfumerie et notamment du métier de
parfumeur
c'est pour ça que jamais plusieurs
fenêtres chose oui jamais notamment les
éléments de la gare l'inad en matières
premières donc la gallina rapidement il
faut le rappeler on va voir si tu as
tort car si vous avez dire tout nuit
j'espère alors fais ton cas rose jasmin
de calabre ce qui est beaucoup mieux la
barre nadja ce n'est pas forcément de
canam ah oui pour les senteurs le parfum
la collection de sautoirs effectivement
bref qu'est ce qu'il y avait d'autres
bergamote
voilà la fève tonka alors la fête on cas
on l'avait la bergamote qui est très
important parce que la bergamote c'est
ce qu'on trouve dans quasiment tous nos
parfums garde ses 5 on met en mal de
tête
la note de tête c'est la première note
qu on va sentir quand on sent un parfum
chez guerlain
donc en fait les notes de tête c'est ce
qu'on appelle le sourire chez nous ça va
être vraiment la première chose c'est ce
qu'on appelle vraiment c'est ce qui va
vous attirer vers un parfum quasiment
tous on est vraiment sur une grande
grande majorité de bergamote fatigue
disons que la note de tête c'est quelque
chose qui va disparaître aussi très vite
c'est dire qu'au bout de dix quinze
minutes on va plus à sentir et on va
passer aux notes de coeur ce qu'on
appelle chez nous la courbe et les notes
de coeur c'est effectivement les autres
de la guerre ni nahd en tout ou partie
parce que la guerre minutes séparent
chaque parfum qu'on fasse attention
parce qu'on met sous les yeux de thierry
wasser m'égare là oui oui keynote
parfumeur alors ça me permet de vous
expliquer ce que c'est qu'un parent
fumeur
oui qu'est-ce que c'est pourquoi gars
est une maison de est un parfumeur c'est
parce que on a en contrat d'exclusivité
1 et qu'ils signent nos parfums
mais thierry l'appeler parfumeur et pas
seulement mené parce qu'en plus il passe
trois mois de l'année à vérifier aller
sur place allaient voir les matières
premières à faire des choix à construire
ces communales de rose et donc on est
vraiment sur quelle atmosphère quoi ces
communales de roses par exemple alors
qu'on vient elle de rose qu'est ce que
c'est la rose on utilise rarement seul
on la mélange on mélange des récoltes
on mélange voire des années pour obtenir
la rose la plus sublime et surtout pour
avoir une rose qui est stable d'une
année sur l'autre et parfums de c'est
comme un bon vin comme les champagnes et
comme le champagne que safari
exactement pour que ce soit révisé à et
qu'on ait une sortie paulo j de rose
très fidèle chaque année donc à la
royale ainsi il ya la rose guerlain et
puis ya surtout une commune elle dans
chaque parfum il prévenu neil par
exemple rossbach barquettes un exécutif
chez nous et travailler sur la rose
c'est vraiment la matière qui au coeur
elle est travaillée plusieurs rose qu'on
a mélangé et harmoniser l'ex héros idéal
en fait la communale rêver c'est la rose
rêver des quarts
donc après alors le parfumeur il a un
petit peu on a des notes de musique
oui j'adore on parle d'orgue l'orgue
ce sont des notes et les notes c'est les
matières premières key les éléments de
la garde l'inad ce sont des notes donc
la bergamote est une note maryse ont
donc là j'en ai amené quelques unes on
les a maintenant en fait en particulier
on
vraiment des extraits des essences de
fleurs
alors après il ya par exemple on la
vanille la teinture donc la teinture de
vanille mais c'est sous forme liquide
d'accord et alors les dés de parfums de
synthèse et parfums de naturel alors à
ya beaucoup alors j'étais sûr que la
saleté sera la synthèse sa phase et
c'est presque un gros mot maintenant pas
du tout en fait la synthèse et la juve
et c'est quelque chose de très très
importants et notamment chez garde on en
est très fier puisque en 1889
j qui a été créée et j qui s'est le
premier parfum moderne en fait alors
pourquoi c'est le premier parfum moderne
c'est justement parce qu'à l'apport de
notes de synthèse
d'où le terme moderne d'où le terme
moderne donc avant qu'est-ce qu'on avait
on avait des reconstitutions de la
nature c'est qu'on avait débloqué des
bouquets de fleurs y avait peu de tenue
de parfum ou alors il y avait de la
tenue parce que c'était une note unique
we know fêter ça voilà c'est par la saur
voilà c'était par exemple de l'angélique
donc le gâteau ils mettaient de
l'angélique et ça sentait c'était un
enregistrement capiteux et là par contre
ça va être la tenue sur trois jours et
lourdes
donc c'était lourd et très bien donc
pour revenir à notre atelier là pour
gagner un autre atelier donc on va vous
expliquer déjà parce que c'est qu'une
note
oui et c'est qu'un accord d'accord et
ensuite on va vous expliquer ce qu'est
un parfum équilibre qu'est ce que ces
attaques et voilà parfum équilibré c'est
un parfum qui va être extrêmement
harmonieux entre les notes de tête donc
le sourire
les notes de coeur donc la courbe des
semaines un fond c'est ça et les notes
de fond voilà les notes de fond c'est la
mémoire en fait du parfum ce qui reste
ce qui va rester le plus longtemps mais
c'est aussi ce qui va lier les lacs de
coeur donc c'est extrêmement important
d'avoir des notes de fond aussi
équilibré d'accord et elle a donc c'est
comme ça qu'on arrive à concevoir c'est
comme ça qu'on arrive à knysna dans un
rare fois mais ce qu'il ya c'est que
nous on va vous accompagner un petit peu
donc en fait oui j'aimais régaler
j'arrêterai là il ya des choses à pas
faire c'est à dire que très vite ça peut
être déséquilibré donc nous on va déjà
vous
vous mettre un accord pour être un
accord natale par exemple de base qu'on
choisit que vous choisissez elle en
fonction de ça ou un accord fraîcheur
par exemple en fonction de ça vous allez
avoir trois matières premières que vous
allez équilibré et y est on est sûr de
ne pas faire de bêtises
alors après de toute façon la parfumerie
c'est subjectif il n'y a pas de
mauvaises réponses
il n'y a pas de mauvais goût mais juste
des choses qu'on aime ou qu'on n'aime
pas enfin ça c'est ma vision
effectivement de la parfumerie donc
effectivement il ya des choses qui
peuvent être malheureuse et puis à des
choses aussi un parfum de l'actuel roi
est clair et qui peuvent plaire et puis
à des choses aussi qui sur la pauvre
évolué différemment parce que l'autre
parfois par exemple qui s'appliquent sur
la peau votre peau val sublimer ou pas
on va toujours essayer son parfum sur la
pauvre et il existe différents types de
peaux il existe différents types de peau
enfin il existe deux ou à dire c'est
vraiment en fonction de chaque personne
d'accord parce qu'il ya des baisses
d'achalandage et ce plus ou moins bien
voilà atteint pas faim voilà et c'est
pour ça que ça parfois finalement est
unique
chacun fait sur la personne sur laquelle
chaque page ma tunique shalimar sur sur
une peau est différente d'une
personnalité en fait toute la magie du
père forzy comment vous recommander de
mètres de se parfumer déjà alors qu'il
ya des choses à faire
le toilettes et règles à suivre le
toilettes n'est pas fait pour être mise
sur la peau logiquement alors on a quand
même fait que nos parfums notamment
d'hommes le twilight peut se mettre sur
la peau mais à la base le de toilette et
fait plutôt pour être mis sur un
accessoire sur ses vêtements sur une
écharpe
voilà usages de l'eau de toilette
ensuite un autre parfum le parfum c'est
effectivement sur la peau et comme
l'extrait sur des zones chaudes
donc faut le mettre effectivement sur au
dessus sur votre et côté décolleté vous
pouvez le mettre derrière les oreilles
vous pouvez le mettre aussi sur les
poignets il faut élargir les creux des
bras autour de la chaleur pour diffuser
parce qu'effectivement le sang va aussi
transporter les odeurs donc c'est
extrêmement important de bien choisir
son parfumage et puis après de l'essence
âge donc on peut même par exemple on
prendre un vol de nuit en extrait
l'appliquer derrière l'oreille ici sur
les poignets et puis ensuite utiliser
l'eau de toilette pour y laisser ainsi
l'âge qu'on les vêtements les
accessoires hockey et dites moi alors là
vous allez je vous ai mené à bien avec
la garmin ah ben voilà alors il ya la
façon qu'a tout le monde la connaît pas
la pelle ton cas elle est pas mal
utilisé notamment en pâtisserie ce que
j'allais vous du chocolat alors il ya
presque des notes chocolatées dedans
après ça ressentir mais il ya des notes
presque de vanille des notes gourmandes
et cette note gourmande c'est vraiment
la faire ton cas qu'il apporte donc ces
issues de marbre qui vient du venezuela
c'est dans une cabosse et puis voilà et
donc faire sort ça et en 107 faivre et
celles à fait d'accord kate une faible
et c'est vraiment quelque chose de très
gourmand qu'on peut utiliser alors ça
s'utilise je ne sais par exemple il ya
des grands cuisiniers qui l'utilisent
sur le poisson maintenant ou dans les
six alors en fait c'est quand elle est
traitée que qu'il ya une odeur très
particulière si vous voulez le mettre en
essence je vous en ai apporté évidemment
ça vient de nos ateliers
donc attention parce que en essence
c'est à ces formes vaut mieux le tenir à
quel que soit mon intention
on était délicieux on en mangerait ouais
c'est vrai que c'est une note très
gourmand bon d'accord donc là on est ce
la fève tonka ensuite alors vous avez
aussi à la matière alors là ce qu est ce
que vous êtes en faire un cliché c'est
la matière la plus noble de la
parfumerie
ce petit peu plus cher c'est plus rare
c'est de l'iris donc les ris en fait
c'est pas la fleur qu'on utilise
c'est le rhizome le rhizome c'est cette
partie de la racine qui sort de terre et
qui est éclairé par le soleil et du coup
c'est ce rhizome qu'on utilise en
parfumerie et on reconnaît très très
bien l'iris chez guerlain puisque ces
sept notes poudrées tous les parfums
degrés alors qu'on retrouve dans leurs
bleus évidemment c'est typiquement
l'iris très bien drôle de forme
c'est une drôle de forme alors y en a
plusieurs et pour ça il faut que ça ait
vu la lumière et l'iris est vraiment
quelque chose de très de très compliqué
à traiter
d'accord écoutez alors ça qu'est ce que
c'est exactement ça savait pas partie de
la guerre milad mais j'ai pensé aux
hommes qui nous regarde pas ce que c'est
qu'un petit verre c'est du vétiver et le
vétiver c'est cette plante par exemple
celui ci vient d'inde
donc c'est cette plante séchée et ça il
mettra d'oise et c'est on va être très
boisée pour les parfums d'hommes et
qu'on revoie l'arrêt à la fin ce sont
des pelures de pommes mais alors pas du
tout apéro nick n'en est pas loin
parce que c'est son fils à la bataille
comme ça c'est agréable a fait plutôt un
agrume et la bergamote
c'est entre de taille entre le citroën
pamplemousse et la bergamote c'est ce
qu'on utilise alors il vient de calabre
où celui ci
décidément qui voit là et c'est vraiment
un magret jasmin selon m en note de tête
vraiment sourire qu'on est très fier
d'eux
mais bon la vanille on connaît pas c'est
pas si est ce que vous savez ce que
c'est la manne ironique c'est alors
c'est les tweets
c'est le fruit d'une fleur bas delà de
l'heure qu'il est
ok donc pour résumer est fait vous
proposez à bas à partir de toutes ces
odeurs
oui donc en fait à partir de notes c'est
bien de savoir quelles notes vous aimez
déjà choisi ce qu'on aime voilà c'est
par exemple je vous donne une baguette
magique vous choisissez trois notes ça
peut m'aider aussi à choisir un parfum
comme là pour moi oui parce qu'il arrive
des gens qui sont à la recherche de leur
parfum toute la vie qui ne trouve pas
voilà voilà donc on peut ce cd comme ça
on peut s'aider en atelier ou tout
simplement venant nous voir dans cette
dans cette boutique parce qu'on va vous
orienter on n'a plus de sens parfum oui
boutique termine également choisir donc
on trouve toujours vraiment toujours
c'est difficile de ne pas trouver son
bonheur
la cote est docteur merci des insultes à
sion au plus vite et vous résoudrez tous
nos problèmes
merci merci beaucoup et unique et à très
vite à travailler dans un mec sans voir